1st question in Portuguese,
it's allowed this time
if he
you like enough RP Assurant Sydney dambassou,
vs Nigeria
Yes.
Not everyone will understand Portuguese,
so I'm going to express myself in Portuguese French if you
want with the word from Portuguese No,
I don't want
No,
wait guys No,
let's stay no,
let's stay serious 1 little We have to be-we have
to be serious because you're the same.
After you will put in social networks to say that the coach,
he does not understand anything.
I stay focused in what I do and really with Uh With a lot of respect because I
know how the environment is and we should not know how to analyze things.
You have to be serious too.
At a given time.